let me tell you something when i was
younger
i'm going to share a personal story for
a second um
i did some modeling when i was younger
and i started doing that when i was like
14 15.
and i was always i had a little curve to
me i wasn't i always had a little bit of
a butt
butt wasn't always trendy now it's
trendy thank you
thank you lord finally the booty thank
you j-lo
anyway
fashionable now wasn't always
fashionable i was little but i had a
little bit of a curve to me and i
remember going to a show a modeling show
that i got invited to i was really
excited i was really young
and the woman was like she's a little
short but also she would need to lose
like 15 pounds
and i was very young and my mom was like
my mom went brooklyn
by the way when you go brooklyn that
means you go crazy on someone i will go
brooklyn here at some point bring fouchi
on we'll go brooklyn
anyway my mom was
horrified and
i went on i spent a few months where i
ate
very little
it really affected me i
became really conscious it was before i
got into exercise before i cared about
wellness i was just like i there's
something wrong with me
and you know what i did
i ate so little i was down to 95 pounds
and when i went to a nutritionist
ultimately she told me that i had shrunk
my organs
okay that's the other side of this
i then once i heard that from someone
something kicked in in my head i joined
the track team i became incredibly
passionate about health and wellness and
food now i mean i eat like a
250 pound man most days
but that was a very brief period of my
life where i fell subject to what
something that hit me at a very
impressionable age and what i'm saying
is this hits people at impressionable
ages too people young girls see this and
they're like oh maybe it's healthy to be
it's not it's not healthy to be grossly
underweight
it's not healthy to be grossly
overweight it puts you at risk so this
is not a commentary from me about
looks
this is a commentary about health and
i'm tired of magazines and i'm tired of
people with an enormous amount of
influence like cosmo
making this about a woke cause or making
this about feelings this isn't about
feelings this is about wellness
and you know when faced with the last
year and a half where you did have a
virus that seemed to target
people who were vulnerable who had these
comorbidities you would think that it
would snap everyone and say wait a
minute enough of this nonsense let's
just get people healthy let's figure out
how we can motivate that how we can be a
positive force of course you have to
motivate yourself you have to want it
yourself but these media institutions
should be a force to assist
not to enable bad behavior
so
listen
i always say this is a time for reality
and
whether you're talking about
obesity
or whether you're talking about gender
or whatever we're talking about here
we're going to be blunt and we're going
to be honest so this is not healthy
this is a media game that's being played
um
and the only person that really loses in
the long run they get a lot of clicks
and you know maybe people buy the
magazine they want to feel good about
themselves that day they buy it they're
the person who suffers really
are the people who who heed this advice
and i shared that personal story with
you because you know it's funny i
remember when i was on the view
i wanted to talk about this stuff there
was a relevant topic and i remember a
she wasn't a producer i don't know what
her title was really her title should
have been gets paid a zillion dollars
and does nothing but she's not there
anymore um but she was like you can't
talk about this and i said why
and you know what she said to me you're
fit
it won't be received well
and i said first of all i work my butt
off
in the gym
and i
deprive myself of i don't eat crappy
food and these are decisions that i make
because i care a and b
how dare you assume that someone would
receive it poorly you know just because
of what i look like i found it so
horrible honestly anyway i couldn't talk
about it i was told no
well i'm talking about it now this is
not about what i look like and that's
why i shared that story with you because
there's been times in my life where i've
been someone who made a bad decision
because of something that was said to me
and it was an unhealthy decision and i
looked horrible
i looked like [ __ ] i looked like i
needed a burger more than anyone
so
that's where it comes from my passion
for health and wellness is my passion
for people
i mean i feed my kid my kid asks for
like he goes down the grocery aisle he
doesn't even know what half that stuff
is and it's my proudest moment he
doesn't know what any of the garbage
food is he's like mama carrot i'm like
you know he ate the other night ground
up organic bison with organ meat mixed
in and he was like
i consider that a good day's work so
this is my life this is my passion
regardless i've had it with media if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
you